hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen heute hier am freitag zu
einem neuen minecraft video ich bekomme
nicht immer so viele kommentare wo leute
schreiben ja luegallee neues minecraft
videos das heißt es ist freitag wochen
wir befinden uns ja auch schon in game
und zwar wenn ich auf der gommer hd
lobby ich zog das ganze übrigens wieder
an meinem laptop ich kann unser thema
zeigen weil sie wer das nicht glaubt
hier
deswegen bin ich dann auch immer so
schlecht ich mein ich bin sonst auch
immer schlecht aber diesmal kann ich
echt gute ausrede nutzen ich weiß gar
nicht was wir heute nicht jetzt habe ich
voll den every day the day
gerade im ohr man auf dieses lied hat
auch einfach schon jeder eine parodie
gemacht oder ich bin jetzt einfach mal
in irgendeiner games lobbyings dem man
immer in meinem kopf every day is taken
a while you hat das doch komplett
parodiert ich glaube einen plan hat
sowas zufrieden monday oder so gemacht
in meinem einem lifestyle wird everyday
center der wahrscheinlich auch npd-mann
der heißen und dann irgendwie so
aussehen als könnten folgen
foot locker
das ist professional products at its
best
bis sich schwierig in der music week ihr
machen wäre das ist ja irgendwie ein
neuer trend dass das jeder auf einmal
plötzlich ein eigenes musikvideo als abo
special warte ich mal bei mir ich meine
ihr habt schon gesehen wie es aussehen
würde wenn ich das machen würde aber
wenn ich meine machen die das weil ich
da bock drauf haben oder weil es geld
bringt ich auch mal die runde geht los
darum soll es gar nicht gehen das war
nur weil ich mit einem kumpel gedacht
atrio das wäre ja wir machen das mal mit
einem einkaufswagen back to my kräftig
kann es sein dass leute schreiben evelyn
zwei kontraste woher wissen die dass ich
entweder okay ich bin wirklich will und
zwar mit dem mein gott ok ich hab'
direkten schwert gefunden das heißt ich
kann direkt läutet boxen aber kommt es
jetzt auch schutzzeit das hier ist ja
auch tatsächlich muss ich sagen eine
meiner lieblings maps also hier sieht
man auch direkt dass ich genau weiß wo
die kisten stehen ihr habt übrigens
keinen ton weil ich irgendwie wie so
werdet ihr nicht geboxt ich weiß nicht
wie man mit quicktime ton aufnehmen kann
das ist irgendwie so eine sache das ist
mir derzeit irgendwie noch ein rätsel
ja sagt ich wollte heute auch eigentlich
in minecraft video aufnehmen wo ich auf
dem handy zocke ich habe mir extra
minecraft dafür auf dem handy gekauft
weil ich habe ein neues handy und muss
deswegen die ganzen schritt neu kaufen
weil ich jetzt alles niedrig gemacht hab
ich dachte halt immer so ne luca du
brauchst nicht alle klar dass ich soll
den zweiten tag gehackt und dann jetzt
hab ich ja mein handy verloren ich werde
euch das video wo ich mir noch mal hier
oder da irgendwo da ist gerade ein video
verlinkt soll aber auch gar nicht thema
der ganzen geschichte sein ich wollte es
auf jeden fall aufnehmen und bin dann
gestern abend habe ich dann versucht ok
welche version bin ich denn version 0.1
4.3 oder so nach dann versucht auch ein
paar server zuzuschauen und auf jedem
server wurde mir irgendwie gesagt you
need to be logged in und dann habe ich
versucht mich einzuloggen und irgendwann
auch kommen fährt ich kann es nicht
verstehen warum kann ich denn kann ich
dich irgendwie wie willst du was wollen
die denn im chat ich grüße gräber und
mega p halt mal ein maul was bin ich
eine werbeplattform da war die mine
jeder spiel zum beispiel games irgendwie
richtig und dann wenn ich das so erzähle
ich einfach mit einem pferd und meiner
komischen ketten wie so tritt wird er
scheiße von oben runter fährt es tut mir
leid ich würde gern mit dir reiten aber
ich muss dich jetzt leider töten weil du
bist mein gott okay okay da hinten kommt
das ist tatsächlich eine sache die hätte
ich so tatsächlich jetzt nicht gerne
eine diktierfunktion man jedenfalls
weiter noch ein paar verschiedenen
servern wie beispielsweise tv gerät oder
boston network oder so vielleicht sagen
euch die namen ja war da konnte ich auch
ganz toll drauf joinen die scheiße war
nur dass ich mich an ein locken sollte
musste ich zeige euch mal ganz gut wie
das aussieht hier ist mein konto auf dem
handy ich klicke auf spielen habt ihr
einen server drin clique darauf der
connector doch richtig toll zu dem
server ist supercool und jetzt will ich
mich hier bewegen will so nach hinten
laufen steht er in new york
youload lockt in und ich dafür dann so
ok wo kann ich mich denn einloggen klick
hier überall rum will jemand schreiben
das ist halt nur den chat und es ging
halt einfach nicht also deswegen weil
sie nicht habt ihr da irgendwelche tipps
dass ich vielleicht nächsten freitag
minecraft auf dem handy zocken kam jetzt
geht aber auch schon direkt weiter und
zwar laufe ich jetzt hier einfach mal
direkt eine mail
können wir dir spaß
das schwert waffen mich bestimmen heute
sind hier tatsächlich sehr stark
ok jetzt beruhigt sich mal ein paar
sekunden später nächste noch echtes in
ordnung also es ist nicht so dass ich
jetzt sagen ich habe jetzt extra richtig
frühe start wird dass wir nur fünf
spieler sind und ich vielleicht einmal
ein bisschen kisten bekomme ich werde
jetzt nicht direkt in die mitte laufen
weil da habe ich trotzdem wieder als ich
sterbe ich glaube einfach direkt die
leiter hoch bin jetzt hier oben und ich
weiß dass es irgendwo hier einen tollen
weg gab mir irgendwann mal gesagt wurde
dass man hier immer so ein paar kisten
bekommen wenn man mich hier in den royal
tollen brot und schuhe toll super
man kann hier oben hin laufen dann hat
man hier oben noch eine kiste wo seine
hose dann schwertes überbewertet und was
haben wir hier in der kiste wir haben ja
alles klassiker gibt mir aber keine
waffen
das daetz mit starts den cd wollen die
mich ach ja wir sind nur fünf spieler
gewesen warum jetzt bin ich
wahrscheinlich im des menschen ja super
ich bin im deathmatch meppen fakten
apfel als waffe kommt doch alle auf mich
ihr wird scheiße auch ohne sachen
zugeworfen brief mit sparte konnten die
mich an ihm egal dass das ist so wie
anna wursttheke früher man trifft so von
der verkäuferin so ein stück wurst freut
sich so richtig und schmeckt einfach
scheiße so war das jetzt gerade ich habe
sozusagen von ihm bekommen das ok cool
jetzt muss ich doch nicht nur mit einem
apfel kämpfen und dann findet nämlich
anderen töten mich sowie einer
grundschule war das bei mir auch mal so
hin
das war es mit heutigen video es hat der
wema keinen sinn
minecraft videos haben irgendwie nie in
senden oder ich meine die sache ist mir
nachts bock das ist so ein mal die woche
mannschaft zocken irgendwann und dann
hochladen so dass ihr von mir nochmal
minecraft sind allerdings bin ich halt
wirklich nicht gut in minecraft und ist
bemängeln noch viele und meinen dann
musst du eigentlich ja kein kraft
hochladen
die frage stelle ich jetzt mal wollt ihr
dass ich freitags immer noch minecraft
hochladen schreibt mal mai kräftig um 3
und wenn jetzt nicht wollt schreibt
anderes die kommentare wegen anderer
kommentare werde ja noch mal okay wie
viele kommentare wurden mit minecraft
geschrieben und dann wird demnächst
einfach weiter beitrag kommen oder
freitags anhalt gar kein minecraft er
und meint was dann in welchen anderen
tagen vielleicht aber auch gar kein
minecraft mehr also da können jetzt
bestimmt sonst wird euch das video
vielleicht trotzdem irgendwie
unterhalten konnte ich mich um eine
bewertung freuen